hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and ladies and gentlemen we have
insane news to talk about today there
was tons of stuff to talk about but
anyway let's just get right into it
without waste any time so first off
congrats to all the samurai for winning
season 2 you can click the I on the top
right to be taken to see the season 2
faction rewards video I did yesterday or
to be at the end of the video if you
don't want to do that but next up weekly
content is a new effect called Blizzard
which will show to you right now
[Music]
so those were cool those are going to be
costing 5,000 whew if you want to
purchase those remember that's five
steel or 5,000 steel each per you know
emote execution it's not five steel for
all three it's not a package next up and
this is the juicy information now I
stated yesterday there's going to be a
lot of very important info being
released in today's stream but no one
knew what it was
let's talk about that so first up they
showed a four on a road map of the game
in the coming months and what's going to
happen in the next coming months there
will be plenty of hero bounding
stability performance new heroes and
maps but we already know that but season
three is going to be starting in August
and end in November of 2017 and it will
contain more public test servers new
maps heroes raise the level cap to 40
with a new legendary rarity which will
extend the gear score beyond 144 and
will continue to add more emotes
executions ornaments and effects like
normal now the best thing is in season 4
which will go from November to February
of 2018 this will come with a new 4 view
for game mode and a ranked feature added
into 4v4 and a new training area to help
players hone their skills you can modify
the AI opponent just like in mortal
combat and have the AI do a specific
move and learn the timing for it just
like warlords own warden's own or even
peacekeeper blood attacks to get you
learning the timing and learning how to
fight those when it comes to the real
match and on top of that there's going
to be more flight systems added and a
new tutorial being added as well and
like I said normally new heroes new maps
emotes executions ornaments effects all
that good [ __ ] and new weapon and armor
variations to enhancer 4 on our fashion
so there's no gear score being added and
season 4 just more different types of
more designs and such and also having
regular balancing updates and patches
now the last and final thing that they
discussed and probably the best thing
I've ever heard so far a migration to
dedicated servers finally to sum it up
for you guys
they realized that p2p servers aren't
exactly working they're still trying to
figure out if they can still work
without dedicated servers but they did
decide they will decide eventually when
it's going to be the time to switch and
and this will help improve stability for
all platforms Coffee cost less
disconnects and hopefully less salt will
be spilled from those disconnects there
is no exactly a confirmed release date
but I'm assuming it'll be between the
end of 2017 or the beginning of 2018
around the time during season four so
we're going to have to wait it out a
little bit longer guys but hopefully
this is going to be worth it and then
that was about it
there wasn't that it was basically 15 to
20 minutes of that the rest was a
faction war statement and then all this
other stuff with the hero series no one
really did a committee care about the
faction war which took up about 80% of
it they did say that about the ornaments
from yesterday's video I talked about
though that they don't the only reason
that one of the few reasons they did it
is because to feel that sort of team
motivation kind of like the whole team
earned its you all get one ornament for
a faction kind of thing and then people
are also confused what the season reward
ornament was so they just made one
instead of doing it twelve different or
fourteen different ones just a few of
their reasons why and then that was
basically it but anyway guys I hope you
guys did enjoy this video tons of
information coming on the roadmap ahead
for for honor I hope you all did enjoy
that I enjoyed watching the stream
hopefully some of you were in the stream
watching it with me and then if you like
I said guys if you did enjoy the video
please leave a like if you disliked it
leave the dislike you already know when
and if you are new hit the subscribe
button and then right next to that there
will be a bell click that bell so you
can never miss one of my uploads and be
notified and be part of that
notification squad but with that guys I
hope you had a great rest of your day
and peace out boys